okay so picture this you've spent 1.4
million dollars on a video game
character and then your dumbass friend
somehow accidentally sells it on an
in-game marketplace for a few hundred
dollars and this actually happened like
in real life and in this case you'd sue
both your friend and the video game
developer let me break this down for you
okay so in China there's this game
called justice online it's a pretty
popular MMORPG made by Nettie's and you
basically run around completing quests
and killing dudes for XP and loot it's
kind of similar to a world of warcraft
and it actually looks pretty sick if
you're into that kind of thing anyways
this dude Lu Mao apologies if I
pronounced your name wrong apparently he
paid the equivalent of one point four
million dollars USD for this incredibly
rare character injustice online which is
frankly [ __ ] absurd now I'm working
with a few different translated news
articles and they all say that when Liu
bought this character it came connected
to a mobile phone number again what I
basically think this means is that when
Liu paid the 1.4 million he got the
character and the account and everything
connected to it so the progression and
items and you know [ __ ] like that
according to everything I've read Liu
then stopped playing the game regularly
and eventually gave the character and
the account to his friend Li mouth Shang
now at this point I had no idea if we've
bought this million dollar account or if
Liu is just really really really
generous
and then eventually Lou asked Lee to
sell him back the account in the
character that he gave him in the first
place and they agreed that Lou would pay
the equivalent of fifty five thousand
USD this all seems super weird and
really confusing now here's where things
get super strange after a marathon
session of gaming Lee posted the
character to justice on lines in-game
marketplace where he and Lou agreed that
Lou would immediately buy it but Lee
accidentally listed the character for
$500 USD
and before anybody knew what the [ __ ]
was going on some random dude recognized
the insanely cheap price snapped it up
and left both Lou and Lee with
absolutely nothing it still you get
nothing
you lose good day sir Lou is
understandably pretty pissed but because
the transaction was made aboveboard
and in the marketplace there was
technically nothing he could really do
well except sue Lee and Nettie's the
people that made the game and like every
other aspect of this story the legal
side of this is really really weird Lou
his friendly and Nettie's all agreed to
mediation everybody just wanted to hash
this out and get it over with
so they used something called the
People's Court mediation platform which
is basically everybody sitting in
different rooms jumping on a Skype call
including the judge who listened to all
of the arguments made his ruling and
then log the [ __ ] off it's basically a
courtroom on the internet now according
to an unverified translation of the
court report which was made public it's
the first time that this platform has
been used to mediate a dispute in the
Sichuan Province of China the idea is is
that they use this digital platform
because they live so far away from one
another now during the dispute Lee the
friend said that he accidentally posted
the character for such a low price
because he was dizzy from playing the
game for way too long okay now
Nettie's his argument was basically hey
we just provide the infrastructure we
don't really monitor anything that
happens in the marketplace and then
there's the random dude who bought the
character and when he was brought into a
mediation he was super confused about
why the hell he was here and he
really didn't think he did anything
wrong why am I here
and then finally lose stated that he
felt like his friend leave posted the
character for such a cheap price on
purpose and pet Nettie's did nothing to
stop it
he understandably feels like he got
ripped off here the judge eventually
ruled that Nettie's had to revoke the
transaction and that our boy Lu was to
be given back the account and the
character with one specific catch he had
to pay the random dude who bought the
character the equivalent of $12,000 USD
now remembers Lu originally paid 1.4
million dollars for this stupid thing
think about that for a second
one day you're browsing the in-game
marketplace and you've realized that
some dummy has listed his insanely rare
character for a stupidly cheap price
you immediately buy it because why
wouldn't you and then you're dragged
before a digital court told that you
have to give back that character you
bought aboveboard and then you're given
twelve thousand dollars as an apology
the judge then went on a rant about the
perils of video games and well I guess
everybody went home happy well as happy
as you can be when you have to pay
twelve grand to a total stranger over a
video game character that you paid a
million dollars for originally video
games are wild man has been used to
mediate a dispute and it's Szechuan is
that how you pronounce it sorry
Szechuan so after after so using
something called the People's Court
mediation platform the next graph down
Sichuan the Sichuan okay